today's guest it's his second time
coming in here and uh man this guy I
know he reminds me of like the
incredible incredible he reminds me
actually have a little bit like the dad
from The Incredibles I think I was gonna
say Incredible Hulk but he's more
evolved than that he is retired Navy
SEAL author and host of the Jaakko
podcast my friend Jaco willing
[Music]
yeah that's the thing about a lobsterman
is really the travel cause people don't
think about that when they see them you
don't think about the travel cost of
going to getting that bastard running it
back and forth and dude they have a new
thing now where they'll have a skill
cream which is like you know a thing the
kids put the money in and they can you
know you do control and you can get a
lobster out and you try to win the
lobster like it said for real
yeah and use it like a shitty bar or
something it's not even like real yeah
so I spent like nine dollars everyone
over the airport I spent about nine I
was trying to get a lobster and then
here's the thing I finally got one
I had to go yeah I had to catch my
flight I can't you know I can't check
this lob oh yeah you know a couple
different flavors now this was tropic
thunder yeah yeah this one you'll end up
in black they don't give to me can you
want to know why because it's really a
pina colada
oh right that's the flavor but I can't
you know Jocko can't be calling
something pina colada right little bit a
little shocked not what we're looking
for a little sake you've already came to
a lot of just call it Tropic Thunder and
you do people when they meet you expect
you to be kind of violent the funny
thing is people meet me and they're like
you're not you know I'm 511 people meet
me I thought you were a lot taller
really it's an and then they and then
yeah so they they think I'm taller
because I'm only 511 and they think I'm
gonna be in black and white because I
always take pictures in black and white
that's a joke but no I mean so that's
what I think people I think when they
finally come up to me you know I'm
pretty laid back
yeah I'm not I'm not going crazy all the
time right some of the time yeah yeah do
you feel like that you whenever you
started podcasting really because so
many people love your show do you feel
like that
in the beginning you were different than
you are now like it's that you were more
of an entertainer like I'm just
wondering what that journeys been like
for you at all honestly no I don't feel
like any different I'm just doing the
same kind of stuff I've always
doing I've always been doing what I'm
doing what I'm doing right now but just
that now there's a window to it for
people to see what's going on and see
kind of life through my eyes right now
I don't it's hard you can't you and you
know the deal you can't be someone else
on a podcast for hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds of hours of talking yeah
play a role you know you just eventually
the real you is there and right so for
me I just always kind of been that's
just me yeah that's just me
do you um do you still do you find is
you getting a little bit you know I know
that Jaco does an age but you know if
you looked at a calendar you've been
alive longer than you were last time I
saw you was maybe a year and a half ago
a year ago mm-hmm some like that yeah
you're one of our first guess I think
actually Nick wasn't he
he was very early on it was over a year
ago but we were nervous bro my search
provider grab good call
I think this guy's coming if I make him
angry and you don't know what's gonna
happen could be the end this guys have
been drinking his own that's my thing
forget what I was even ask you man oh
there you go that's what you were
talking about your memory I listen to
your podcast today you were talking
about your memory failing quite a bit
yeah I think this Bono you were talking
about your emotional memory that's why
you keep making the same mistakes all
through some mistakes yeah see that's I
I think I have a good emotional memory
really like locked why I remember what
that feels like I'm not doing that again
see [ __ ] eyes for some reason I forget
it's like it's yeah it's like that kid
with the stove kind of it's like yeah it
is don't I it's just like yeah I found
myself just running on the same circles
um yeah recent been trying to get a
little bit more into finding just
motivation mm-hmm because then at least
I'm like active in each I've been trying
to get more active into each into my
days day so then at least I'm like not
just like playing from behind all day I
don't feel like if I active do you mean
like some kind of physical activity you
just mean more proactive in the way you
approach your day
both actually some more physical
activity instead of just thinking like
the second I think okay
for a gym where I should go to the run
or I should you know set get an
appointment for a train or you know I
know you don't have a trainer but you
couldn't even imagine with a whistle but
but yeah it's like I just go ahead and
do it and then and then just to try and
approach us my day a little bit more
like just like okay I want to do this I
call it like going on offense instead of
being on defense you just go on offense
yeah I'm gonna make some stuff happen I
thinking about doing this and that's a
good attitude when you think about
something thinking about doing it just
go do it yeah don't waste time thinking
about even what you're gonna do at the
gym just go to the gym you can figure it
out when you get there or your trainer
can tell ya ya good my brain man it just
yeah once it gets into my brain that's
where it's not good you know it's like
when I'm in action that's when yeah
everything will work out usually okay as
long as I get my action going you know
so yeah for recently it's just been just
something I guess I've been struggling
with is just finding that motivation so
but now I feel like I'm getting a little
bit more like alright let's just go you
know let's go let's get in motion and I
know it but sometimes it's like I'll
have learned a lesson and then it'll
just kind of fade away a little bit you
know and then off to or you know the
value like the new practices I have in
my life sometimes they go by the wayside
and it's like I have to kind of
recalibrate yeah well I always tell
people you can't sit around waiting to
feet until you're motivated to do
something is if you sit around waiting
till you're motivated do something who
knows when that's gonna come it may come
but may not come yeah and you may only
come twice a week and if it only come in
twice a week that's that's a lot less
than you actually need so you don't wait
you don't like just put put the
discipline on you know you put the
discipline on yeah and when you wake up
you go do what you're supposed to do and
you the crazy thing is you speaking of
emotional memory you know when you get
done you're gonna feel better like
that's a guarantee if you go to the gym
and you get your workout in or you do
whatever thing you know you're supposed
to do it's a guarantee that when you get
done you're gonna feel better so
remember that emotion right and and put
that thing into play so that you can
actually you know get done the way
you're supposed to yeah I wonder why
then sometimes like I'll know that I'll
know
how to help myself and sometimes I still
don't want to that's the whole world
right that's the whole world everyone
you know what are you gonna
who wants to eat the broccoli instead of
the Twinkie right people like oh they're
they're gonna eat the Twinkie everybody
knows that it's bad form yeah they're
just what you you ever been to a
7-eleven you know what do they sell it
there they don't sell Brock we've
careful they just sell candy straight
sugar mainlining sugar corn syrup get it
in the veins yeah and people are that's
all day that's what happens yeah so it's
not like you're you're different you're
in the same boat as everybody else yeah
yeah and that's I guess that's a good
point like that's the boat you have to
get out of it's like it's not like
that's a if you're behaving that way
that you've been sentenced to that
that's the baseline yeah yeah did you
know no different than everybody else
right that's the baseline is that yeah
it's not like I'm [ __ ] man I'm not
making great decisions for myself most
people aren't yeah that's why there's a
difference between when we do when we
don't in the end and right and kind of
getting out of that really it's like a
slumber I feel like it gets into all
once it starts to seep into one aspect
of my life it kind of starts to seep
around you know well the good thing is
is when you put some discipline in your
life that seeps around - yeah so when
you start doing things right you start
doing more things right right yeah I
mean it's classic right you have one of
those weekends we like you know what I'm
just I think I'm just gonna I'm just
gonna order a pizza well then so you
order that pizza
you know from wherever gray block that
gray block hitter yeah and you get the
triple cheese and you get the meat
whatever yeah and your and so then you
just dive into that thing and you and
what does that do well that kind of you
think well since I did that
I'm not even to go for a run to rice I'm
just gonna kick back and then you know
you just start going down that I'm gonna
get ice cream I'm gonna do weed or
something yeah and then I don't watch my
children yes gonna call my mom you know
little decisions by when you say you
when you're like about to dial the
number and then you say you know what no
I'm just gonna make a make a salad right
now and put a chicken in it yeah and
just eat that you mean
hmm and then you get down with that you
say you know I feel pretty good yeah oh
my god get a little run
get a little run done then you get a run
in yeah clean my [ __ ] car but that's
what happens so the little decisions
they build up so the the bad decisions
build up so that's what happens now
that's not an excuse to say okay now I'm
gonna make 28 bad decisions in a row
right what it is it's an indicator you
say oh I just made one bad okay stop
reset the pizza was good fine let's get
back on the path what now that's a
mistake that people make yeah and by the
way that's a mistake that people can
make for like nine years it's funny um I
wonder as especially do you find as we
get into more of like an automated
almost an automated humanity in a way do
you feel like it's becoming harder for
people to make good choices for
themselves are they're up against like
greater evils or do you have did you
ever have any thoughts like that or it's
still I suppose they're some of I mean
let's face it it's a lot more easier to
order a pizza than it is to go out and
Huck a spear Adam yeah yeah so so that's
definitely a difference and it's and
even today I mean you know you live in
LA I live in San Diego you could pretty
much get anything you want anything into
your house in maybe two hours maximum
yeah so if there's some evil food that
you want to eat you can get it and it's
going to be delivered to your door so
that even the resistance you know some
people are like well you know I'd really
like to have but I'm not gonna get here
I'd really have a chocolate doughnut
right now but I don't want to go all the
way to maybe that maybe that saves some
people now that that saviours golf
because now they're just they're just on
their phone and they got chocolate
doughnuts stacking up with the front
door so that could be a problem that
could be a problem do you so so if
that's starting to occur then then there
really is kind of becoming a line
between if we're gonna be strong enough
to make choices for ourselves or if
we're gonna
if we're gonna not you know like do you
think that or is that you think it's all
it's just still the same and there's
always been like you know back in the
day and maybe a duck would wander up to
your door you'd like all never have any
duck you know and then a [ __ ] Mallard
lands you know when you're welcome and
you're like oh you know yeah I think we
also but I think we're more aware now of
the effects the negative effects of this
bad stuff you know cuz let's face it
when I was a kid and I was thirsty
probably the same as you when I was a
kid and I told my mom like I'm thirsty
she'd be like cool there's cokes in the
fridge yeah and I'd go drink three of
them right like no factor this was just
what it was
hey I'm hungry what am I going to eat a
Snickers bar
yeah that would that was they had some
little motto Snickers satisfies that so
hey payday payday bar it was a help oh
yeah I was like hey this is good for you
which I didn't even really compute that
I was like it's food right foods good
for you so so we're more aware like even
my I got one daughter that's only ten
years old I mean she knows that she'll
like local there's a tonne of sugar in
this she's ten years old so I think
people are more aware I mean you know my
parents uh it wasn't them being bad
parents right it was just that what was
going on but it was just what was going
on the the dang what what they called
funny bones have you ever had a funny
moment it was like chocolate called it
was like get up now it was kind of like
a Twinkie situation but it was chocolate
it had chocolate draped over it but then
they inside was a was creamy peanut
butter filling rule so you know you
could just you could and it wasn't
nothing like the way I'd like to be
buried actually yeah it's not a bad deal
at least throwing a couple in there in a
coffin food funny bones right there
Drake's I couldn't remember that so yeah
my mom would buy you know like they got
the ten pack right there huh yeah my mom
will buy like three of those and just be
hey what are you gonna have for what do
you have for breakfast a funny bone
maybe three so I think even though
there's some things that make it easier
to be Oh less healthy nowadays right I
think at least we're aware of it
not we're not mainline in coca-cola in
the morning yeah yeah I guess there is
it yeah remembering and his kids would
make that sound after after we drank it
was like that was like a big thing but
yeah getting a coke was and your parents
had Diet Coke and you thought that was
crazy like what [ __ ] creepy senior
Siffin that [ __ ] but yet so yeah it's
like I actually I'm pretty sure I
remember I think I remember a world
before Diet Coke actually there was
something called tab oh yeah it was
really had a very strange fun I think
that was the first kind of diet soda
oh really yeah that I can remember cuz I
coke was just coke there wasn't any even
anything else it was yeah it wasn't coke
light and coke everything else it was
just coke yeah 97 coke yeah and they're
supposed to refresh you that's insane we
think about that but that's how it was
but yeah I guess I wonder if there was
any positives to it I mean sugars such a
killer sugar so how much care how much
sugars in this zero
oh really yeah so what tastes good what
what's making your your sweetness up a
little bit oh it is is that there's
something called monk fruit in it which
is religious now it's it's something not
not very religious it's something like
you know eighty-seven thousand times
more sweet than sugar now though I don't
know what the numbers but it's something
like that so it's super sweet three
times softer than cotton yeah yeah yeah
but it's just it's a fruit and so we
just put a little bit of that in there
and it makes it taste weed and it tastes
natural so yeah yeah it does it's pretty
smooth it so they're all go is jhaqo go
mm-hmm yeah and your kids after dinner
time yeah there's too much caffeine in
it for a kid there's ninety five
milligrams of caffeine if [ __ ] man yeah
yeah so are you gonna go are you gonna
go crazy now I don't wanna join the ROTC
no it's like the same as a cup of coffee
okay so would you guys um did you do
ROTC when you're younger no because that
I remember there was this group of our
schools like ROTC know for sure nobody
told us first of all what it was right
which is a huge long
because suddenly after school do be
these kids running around school with
wooden gun did you like what is going on
yeah for me I wasn't into that part of
the military I wasn't into thinking hey
let's march around yeah I was into the
commando stuff so what I actually got in
trouble on the on the soccer team cuz I
was leading runs and I was singing
Cadence's and I remember getting in
trouble for you know singing the cadence
of Ho Chi Minh is a son of a [ __ ] you
know which I was into that kind of thing
we all play in Ho Chi Minh you're like
oh it's us it's a goal it's a goal not a
foxhole yeah yeah so I would but we
didn't even have our two ROTC my score
grew up in a really small town in New
England there was 85 people in my
graduating class wow it's really small
so so was it more the leadership then
that you was it I'm trying to figure out
like kind of pinpoint what it was and
was it bro do you remember when you were
a little kid like but pretending that a
stick was a gun oh yeah GI Joe oh that's
it man that's it and I that was just a
real strong feeling for me every kid
that's all we did yeah most of the kids
stopped doing that yeah I didn't Wow and
when people would when people would look
and say oh the [ __ ] elbow crawling
across the graduation stage people see
somebody walking around with a briefcase
when you're a little kid and be like wow
that person like they're getting in a
Cadillac like oh that person's something
like powerful a banker or something
right and I'd never had that thought I
only thought whoa that guy's got a
machine gun or that guy's getting into a
tank yeah and that just was what I
always wanted to do Wow that's what I
said I just never stopped yeah yeah and
here you are mm-hmm we had so many uh
wonderful questions that came in I just
want to get into some of them because
they'll lead us into some conversation
stuff too
sounds like you're out of cool good
questions oh no I'm not I'm not but
people had so many good ones it's
awesome
yeah it's really really we look over
there is that the deal yeah we'll just
look over here yeah
cool hey guys Jason here I just wanted
to reach out and say thank you for what
you guys are doing I do have a question
it gotta fit both of you I'm gonna whew
I guess a podcast you guys are talking
about how you're gonna keep your
emotions right and keep them under you
know keep them under wraps if you will
I'm doing my best
I'm currently at 440 pounds I was
diagnosed with severe sleep apnea I
stopped breathing like 64 times an hour
which is insane yeah I'm a little
machine now so I'm getting that right
trying to get my eating right with the
Kido and the whole good thing but I've
had this peaks and valleys of how I've
gone up and down with my weight
struggling with food so I guess you know
it might be a good person ask how do I
keep my emotions in check so I continue
to make good decisions and how can I
actually make this work so I make a
lifestyle change forever all right thank
eyes okay gang
I'm gonna run gang bruh and a life you
want to be able to live man I can't
imagine but you don't must feel trapped
I think at that weight yeah yeah but I
mean but motivated sounds motivated yeah
it'd be real easy to think hey you're
trapped at that weight but man he's
alive he's on the right path right now
you know and I would say I always tell
this to people you you can't let your
emotions dictate what you're gonna do
well it's kind of conversation we just
had cuz I mean if you think about it
motivation is really just an emotion
yeah it's just an emotion you feel
really good and motivated you can't let
your emotions dictate your actions yeah
you've got to let your your logic
dictate your actions and hey it's not
gonna feel good every day I just this
morning I I didn't feel like working out
I was sore I've been working it hard for
the last few days I did not feel like
working out at all and I went down there
and I went through the motions and and
you know what you know people say you're
just going through the motions I was
like yes I was but that's better than
not going through the motions because I
got down there I did the work but wasn't
the best workout I've ever had no
records were broken
nothing was crazy but I went down there
and did what I'm supposed to do there
was no motivation involved whatsoever
zero right I was unmotivated I was
motivated to to just
Mogul into bed yeah but no you gotta get
up so don't let your don't let your
emotions dictate it and peaks and
valleys guess what that's what life is
yeah life you're gonna have you're gonna
have times when you feel good you can
have times when you feel bad and you
can't let those things be so broad span
so you can't let those Peaks be so high
in those valleys be so low that it
throws you off course when I feel down
it's like okay you know what that's
gonna pass yeah and the way you make it
pass is through action it's what you
just said yeah you said you know what I
get going that's what I'm good
that's the same thing to Jason hey Jason
if you're not feeling like it you know
what do what Theo does just get stop
that stop the thinking about it and just
go in little for the walk go get on the
treadmill get whatever exercise you're
gonna start doing start doing it and the
other thing is look man this is a long
war this isn't a battle that you're
gonna fight one day two days you're in a
campaign yeah in a campaign World War
two four years of combat to get where
you want to go maybe seven years maybe
eight doesn't it does I don't know but
part of you don't have to think if only
it could be at the end I mean enjoy
where you're at right now yeah I know it
sounds crazy but you know you said to
hang trapped in man you're lucky you're
lucky you know I got friends that have
been so severely wounded ya know they
can't go for them they lost their legs
they lost their arms and lost their
vision whatever hey man you're you're
you're good to go
you good to go go out yeah and like you
said live yeah I think it
I mean it's yeah I mean it's that's it
it's like you you got to keep you have
to get moving you know you have to get
it's just it's so funny man because
that's one thing that I think in the
past year that I've definitely had an
easier time with is when I don't feel
good even its recently man knowing
really starting to know at a real level
not just like hearing and hoping but
knowing that that that will pass that
though how I'm feeling is not always
real some of us are you know it's just
like we just have may be thicker
emotions or deeper emotions you might
have bigger highs and bigger lows
but it's almost like nobody told us in
the beginning like hey how you feel
isn't exactly what's going on sometimes
like yeah you might feel like [ __ ] but
you just like you just keep going you
know
and yeah the unmotivated it's funny it's
like when I'll go to the gym and
something I don't want to or when I'll
go for a run once I get to about eight
minutes and you start to hit that sweat
a little bit about seven and a half
minutes that's when I start to actually
start to almost feel ashamed of myself
sometimes for even feeling good a little
bit because I was so set on like oh I'm
gonna have such a shitty you know oh I'm
gonna show myself I'm gonna have a
shitty time I'm gonna have a shitty day
and then I'll get kind of moving and
stuff and I'm like [ __ ] man I'm almost
enjoying myself a little bit you know
what's you know I'm thinking about right
now because people always ask well how
did you get this way you like to me oh
yeah and as I'm sitting here thinking
about one of the things that you got
obviously got bit by an American Eagle
know it's think about this so when I was
in the SEAL Teams and as I moved through
my career I moved into leadership
positions right well when I was in
leadership positions you can't you can't
be moping around because if your guys
see you moping around or being negative
they're gonna react they're gonna follow
you right they're gonna they're gonna
take the way your actions are so at some
point pretty early I realized oh if I
act like that everyone's gonna act like
that so I can't act like that
so if I don't feel like doing something
the last thing I'm gonna do is say hey
guys oh man I don't feel like doing no I
would never let those words X in my
mouth and by the way in the SEAL Teams
that's kind of the way it is you know no
one's like no one will admit to uncle
hey I'm cold right now
you never hear you never hear someone
say I'm cold can I borrow your jacket
yeah it's better for you it's better to
freeze right yeah or hey I'm tired no
one's gonna say that so that's where you
get you realize and so then when you
power through it and you power through
it over and over and over again you
realize you know what my emotions as you
said they're not real yeah they're not
they're not they don't have to impact
the way I'm actually going to act yeah
Jason that's a muscle it really is a
muscle it's like it really is a muscle
of breaking through that little barrier
it's so thin too that barrier if I'm not
gonna do this it's so it's crazy because
it feels so heavy sometimes but it's so
it's so thin man
and it changes like you know like I'll
and then the rest of my day is always
better but always better I try to
explain that to people all the time even
though it sucks to leave your pillow in
the morning the rest of your day will
absolutely be better and you're right
that little barrier the hardest part
about the hardest part about the gym is
going just get in there that's the
hardest part yeah the hardest part about
not eating whatever sort of crap is
sitting for bag of Cheetos the the is
sitting there if you just take and throw
it away and just walk away you'll be
fine you won't think about it you're not
gonna be thinking about it for an hour
right how long how long if you just
throw that bag of cheetos we're not
gonna be like in your journal not
despondent dear chester yeah yeah sorry
what happened yeah i'm just moving on
yeah good so put yourself somewhere else
throw the Cheetos as far as you can
throw them yeah walk away walk away
Jason is what's interesting is you
really your life has set you up with the
real you've got a journey in front of
you kind of which is kind of cool
mm-hmm it's kind of cool to have you're
at war yes you have a mission yeah
that's awesome it's pretty cool yeah
because a lot of a lot of life sometimes
it's just you're not finding your war
sometimes you know some of it is um you
know some of that aimlessness sometimes
uh but you've got it man and I think
yeah that emotional part is is just
don't believe those feelings sometimes
because we all have them I mean I think
one of Jacko's skills or one of his you
know skills besides being a beverage
entrepreneur it's actually pretty like
scare I got the recruiters inbound if I
one more sip somebody's gonna parachute
into the ceiling but part of one of his
things that he seems to have really
mastered is not letting that first voice
have be the loudest you know and having
your own voice against that
[Music]
good luck Jason man maybe check in why
don't can we check back in with Jason
maybe absolutely and just kind of and
just see what's going on because I would
even love to know you know how
how you move forward like what happens
emotionally you no matter what direction
you're kind of going in with your you
know with some of your choices if you
know what's making you feel down or or
or what's making you feel up you know we
had one question I know about tapping
out do we have that one yes I do
all right I want to know from Jocko and
their I love you boy you're my boy feel
but I want to know well quick he things
can be able to tap you out just cuz I
think you'd be kind of interesting I
think some other people will want to
know too but you're still my boy oh I
[ __ ] love you bro but uh how quick do
you think how good does Jocko think he'd
be able to tap you out and then also do
you think you'd be able to tap him out
like if you did like bath salts or
something I know that [ __ ] has people
feeling just being with loopy bro that's
my question
dang man that's a good question dude
have you ever trained jujitsu before I
mean I've trained like I've had you know
I've chased like a small animal around
the house have you ever changed you know
I have no yeah that's gonna be a problem
okay yeah it's gonna be a problem it's
not it wouldn't take very long okay no
it wouldn't take very long what do you
think you three man and this is the
thing man is I always try to explain to
people it's not because I'm a badass at
all right it's because it's because I
train for a really long time so what
like sport are you really good at
probably outdoor activities probably
good sport bro sorry probably basketball
okay so let's say you and I were let's
say I never played basketball ever in my
life right and you and I played
one-on-one and how long how would I do
you think I'd even score one single
basket I bet you'd score one based on
some of your abilities okay so one
single basket and you beat me eleven to
one yeah right so in jiu-jitsu it's the
same thing I just know I know the game
you don't know the game at all and so it
would be really easy it'd be really easy
not just for me but anyone that trains
you Jitsu what do you think three four
minutes probably just tap you out yeah
no no no what if I was wearing like a
real slippery suit or something that
might gain you a little bit of time but
we're talking sub but one minute unless
you're yeah yeah
what if it's windy yeah
before I'm good in the wind you've
trained before ago right you've trained
I wasn't okay then that that's where
that that's where that little little
hesitation because that's what's amazing
about it same thing when I first trained
elbows when I first trained I just
graduated from SEAL training Jesus and I
thought I was the bird yeah and I was 19
years old
I was you know you just got done the
most elite training in the world and all
this stuff at 19 yeah and so this this
old master chief like the oldest guy I'd
ever seen Jesus he was probably like 40
I was looking at my grandpa you're like
nothing Oh [ __ ] with the drivers last
so he goes he goes you know who wants to
learn how to fight and I'm like me yeah
so he brings us out bring us on the mat
and just lined up there's like five of
us new guys and he tapped us all out
damn less than a minute each and that's
what it is
that's what jujitsu is that's why people
that's why that's why people talk about
it a lot because when it first happens
to you you can't even believe it so you
and immediately when you get tapped out
for the first time when you're 19 years
old and you're like ah yeah I can take
anybody Oh cuz I don't know yeah exactly
you're just pouring shots of your own
urine oh yeah there may be of us getting
after that urine oh yeah I don't have a
core brother gives a [ __ ]
but 19 year old piss is [ __ ] you know
it's just actually I do you ready I like
where you're at but you're not really
there scientifically so yeah that's what
happens you you just don't know and
jujitsu is a really powerful powerful
thing and you should go train some time
you know I really want to go train and I
need to go train up and try and what
I've been focusing on this you've been
saying that for a while now well one of
my fears is that uh I'm not flexible
enough that has nothing to do with
anything it has nothing to do with you
not training I have people that come to
my gym that start start jujitsu when
they're 52 years old Wow or 43 years old
or whatever it doesn't matter you can
get in there and you can train be
careful you know you don't want to try
with like some 19 year old kid that's
been training for like six months right
that's all crazy right that is nothing
to lose don't don't go with him because
he's gonna he's gonna take your arm and
put it on his wall at home and yeah so
watch out for that guy but other than
that if you find some people that we're
gonna relax and be cool and yeah you
should definitely start trying to in
jujitsu yeah I think you should do is
stretch I mean I hope you had one like
some kind of stretching protocol that's
a no-no yeah no sir why no why cause
stretching is so unsatisfied yeah I find
it so unsatisfying um if there's the the
the Achilles heel the Achilles heel for
me or just the thing that I really don't
like doing even though I know it's been
officials I don't like stretching a lot
yeah so cuz there's just you just don't
you don't get done you don't arrest said
when you always feel better
yeah there's less of that feeling when I
get done I don't I'm not walking around
like yo I just got done stretching out
look how far up like a reason I don't do
that so that's why stretching but yeah
if you got a bad back you should
definitely there's protocols you can do
that'll definitely help your back out
for sure for sure yeah no I think I
think maybe it is time man I think I
need some stuff that makes me feel yeah
I think just that kind of I think I
could recently I realize I need to put
more things into my life that are just
fun you know exciting just new
adventures that keep me kind of like
motivated and keep me doing things like
sometimes all I even do is just either
podcasters do stand-up comedy and it's
great but it's not like sometimes adding
to my experience yeah I loved you Jitsu
because it's always you can always get
better you always get tangled up you
always get tapped out by somebody it's
always evolving that's what makes it
that's one of the things that makes it
really cool is just how much it evolves
all the time and it's you don't ever
feel like I got this you never feel like
that you always feel like I could get a
little bit better yeah I like that
here's a guy that has something to say
do max for Mississippi
Jaakko what was the light hunt for the
first time with John deadly Tamara
Haynes Joe Rogan Andy stump
yeah man just got back from a hunt up in
northern Utah al hunt and I mean you
couldn't really ask for a better crew of
people as you heard he just rattled off
yeah I don't know mr. Dudley but Haynes
is very intense he loves to hunt you
know the upman Dudley's the same way and
then Rogan he loves to hunt and then
Andy Stumpf loves to hunt as well it was
my first time going bow hunting and yeah
it was awesome it was just awesome from
the whole experience was awesome how
nice was the place you guys went was it
a nice place it was a nice place and
that's that's another thing so just to
clarify and and people there's no
there's like you know how in different
parts of the world different things in
the world there's like a different
there's like a little subculture in
there right yeah so like you're a
comedian and I'm sure there's people
that are like well you know you got such
good deal cuz you got to this thing and
people look down on these so there's all
that stuff I don't really know too much
about it but you know we got I got the
luck and the blessing of going on a
really awesome hunt okay it's something
called private land right which means
not everyone can go hunt there so
there's more animals in there is if you
do something called a public hunt right
so public hunt is like you're out there
and anybody can hunt there right maybe
there's an animal maybe there's not say
there's somebody on drugs maybe
somebody's yeah man yeah so you might go
out for 5 8 10 days you might not even
see unanimity animal that you're hunting
for so I got really lucky really blessed
to to be tied in with this group and and
go out there and the hunt was awesome
the whole experience was awesome
there's something very primal right
about going for going hunting kind of
like for me it's like jiu-jitsu I would
say there's something primal about doing
jujitsu right like you're fighting you
know when you were a little kid and you
you and your friends will just get
sticks and put on helmets and just go to
war with each other right
that's what we used to do and that's
what kid that's what little boys do that
right right so there's something primal
and instinctive about just war right
same thing with hunting so you're out
you're stalking you're sneaking around
it has a lot of correlations to my old
job being in the Navy where you're
you're trying to be quiet
we're setting up tactics you're you're
trying to maneuver on these animals
yeah just like you'd be maneuver on the
enemy you got a raccoon under a
spotlight you like tell us what you know
recycling bin
yeah so that was awesome and you know
going up there it was really nice for me
because I'm very busy all the time I've
always got stuff going on and we got out
there and like the internet didn't even
it worked like there was one little hill
you could go over we'd get a internet
for for three minutes but I just because
of that I just said you know I'm just
gonna shut this thing off so it's really
nice for me to be up there and and then
you have one mission you know and that's
what's cool about that's one of the best
things about my old job you got one
mission Wow you go on deployment you
pack up your bags you leave the world
behind and you have one mission and that
is to close with and destroy the enemy
take care of your guys that's what
you're doing so that's what this that's
what that's my first experience of
hunting was okay my I'm disconnected
from the outer world and I have one
mission so it was awesome
interesting it was just a big
personality I mean those are like a big
you know that's a unique group that your
way oh yeah it's a it's the thing is I
mean all that all those guys are just
great guys yeah you know I've known I've
known Joe Rogan for a while and people
oh yeah I'm sure people ask you what's
he really uh yeah what's he really yeah
it's like he's like just exactly what
you see is what you get yeah he's super
nice guy the same thing with I mean
Dudley has invested personally in like
he wanted me to get in hunting yeah gave
me a bone again this is where it sounds
crazy that I could be so lucky in my
life that one of the best archery
hunters in the world would say hey I
want you to get an archery here's a
bow let me teach you campaigns you know
campaigns same thing he was super cool
debriefing me on stuff and then my buddy
Andy Stumpf which you know Andy and I we
worked together a little bit in the SEAL
Teams but you know I just being out
there with one other SEAL yeah we have
we just have a connection that you know
I you know you can only have with that
Brotherhood so hey man it was just it
was awesome I look to doing it again and
for me you know you talked about getting
in this new stuff for me it was totally
new I never shot a bow and arrow before
and and then I had the opportunity to to
train and then go out and do it so yeah
it was awesome I appreciate I appreciate
everyone that I just mentioned in that
group yeah just great guys was the
experience where you um when you're so
when you're getting directions like on
something you've never done
how is that for you like coming from a
place where it's like you know you were
you know you're used to having a good
knowledge base of what's going on in
your field do you find yourself to be a
pretty good student do you find yourself
having a tough time being us I'm I'm all
ears man yeah no problem I have no
problem at all saying look I have no
idea you know tell me what to do tell me
what to do from the get-go there's no
problem at all with that how'd you find
the Bohanon was it pretty tricky or did
you find it was yeah no it's definitely
tricky
it's definitely tricky how long can you
shoot a detoxes you just [ __ ] uncle
Rico in that [ __ ] over the mouth yeah
it'd be like you know are like way up in
you know really good on a cube has been
an Anytime Fitness for a couple hundred
years firing that thing obviously the
better the better you are the further
range you can go you know so but I would
say the average normal hunter is
probably trying to go 50 something
meters you know something like that
is around you know that's that's that's
me well yeah there's try out trying to
get to that's a little video of me
trying to get tuned up before I and did
you find like did you start to notice
that you lost is it a really fine line
between like how accurate you can be and
the amount of strength you're using and
stuff like that or it's not really a
strength thing it's it's technique you
know so this you can't like just say
anything man
just like anything I mean jiu-jitsu is
not about strength right that's
it's perfectly never been rock climbing
before oh yeah like rock climbing is so
much technique so much and and you think
oh you know cuz I can do like like
Frances I can do a lot of pull-ups I do
a lot of pull-ups I could see that and
you think oh you know you can just grab
on the rocks and climb no no no there's
so much technique involved that you have
to learn the technique just like
basketball just like playing guitar you
have to practice you have to learn the
technique and that's the same thing with
archery and then you just have to do it
over and over again like shooting a gun
you got to do it over and over again you
got to keep those reps in did you find
that as though as the week progressed
the time you guys were out there that it
got easier for you and did you find you
well we weren't shooting a bunch we were
patrolling through the woods you know
and that was cool again I was out with
John Dudley who's a master hunter I'm
just and it's it's awesome because
you're on patrol and I keep calling it
on patrol but yeah I suppose it's called
we were hunting and we're walking but
for me my mind I was on patrol Oh hail
you know so it was good what's that oh
you're like oh that Bisons from China
like I shoot yeah yeah
dude imagine sneaking a jinglebell out
there with you that would ruin everybody
five you'd have to be real quiet yeah
yeah no we want to bring your jingle
bells out there even one will shake the
world up on a hunt gotta be careful that
yeah yeah I don't know about you guys
but I lost eleven dollars last week
playing yeah gambling but that's a good
thing is you know I laid a couple
parlays laid a few bets you know and I
did it on my bookie my bookie it's a
place where you know if you want a wager
on you know you like the Redskins you
think they're gonna beat somebody you
wager on them drop a wager you know you
think maybe the Orioles is gonna beat
the UM
the Clippers drop that wager daddy
regardless whether you've been betting
for years or you're ready to just play
for the first time even my bookie is
your best bet this season between
football season the MLB playoffs and the
start of the NBA and NHL it's time to
get off the sidelines and get in
on the action if you really want to
support your team drop a couple dimes on
them get in the game with my bookie dot
AG and if you join right now my bookie
will double your first deposit yep
doubling use promo code théo th EO to
activate that offer that's promo code
Theo to double your cash visit my bookie
dot AG today you play you win you get
paid and I got to let you know that this
past weekend has also brought to you by
a company called skill share and you
know everybody I used to have skills man
I remember I could uh I remember I could
hold my breath until I passed out and
then I'd wake up you know and my friends
van everybody has different skills man
and skill share is an online learning
community for creators with more than
25,000 classes in design business and
more cheffing recipe work painting
carbon rhe you'll discover countless
ways to fuel your curiosity creativity
and career they have classes in social
media marketing mobile photography and
creative writing you want to learn
graphic design then you can take graphic
design basics core principles for visual
design one of the most popular courses
join the millions of students already
using skills share today our listeners
can get two months of Skillshare for
free that's right skills share is
offering tpw listeners two months of
unlimited access to over 25,000 classes
for free go to Skillshare dot-com slash
Theo von again go to Skillshare comm
slash Theo von to start your two months
now that Skillshare comm slash Theo von
what else forgotten it so we had Jocko
give some advice to will he yes he's a
22 year old who knocked up his 19 year
old girlfriend and he felt like he
ruined her life
and he actually had the baby at the end
of August and we are gonna call and
check in with will
assuming yeah because we played a good
video and you gave him some good
suggestions and stuff we just wanted to
check in with him we thought it would be
a just kind of a neat moment for him for
sure okay cool
we're gonna call him right now then
Colin will come if he goes hopefully has
a job he got off in five East Coast time
he's a traffic oh hey we'll hey well I
was with Sean what's up man is the CEO
how are you yeah you got that Oh spring
rocking back there huh
you got that plebeian bleep I think they
call him dude I just wanna I wanted to
say thanks for reaching out a while back
I know you were thinking that you know
you were you know you had the kid on the
way and and we had Jocko willing uh you
know we we had him offer up a video of
some suggestions and stuff and then I
have Jocko here in studio so I just
wanted I wanted to just kind of follow
up and see how fatherhood is going for
you and Jacko's got a couple of
enlistees that have come out of his own
road them I guess to say the least yeah
I'll let my daughters know how's it
going over there what's up man oh good
man what's up Jack are you doing I'm
doing awesome how about you I'm good
first of all say thanks for calling Theo
thanks for calling Jocko I'm really
nervous to do this dude I'm nervous too
bro you don't at least want to sit by
Jacopo it's a cat nerve-wracking bro
it's like being in every high school
class you've ever been in all at once
forever and a teacher it doesn't bug it
just wants to strangle you dude I was
nervous very scary to me and I helium I
gained two pounds of muscle mass look at
his Instagram a couple of weeks ago
[Laughter]
but no Jocko wouldn't know how them feel
how's it going it's going really good
it's really rewarding
I mean I'm loving it she's she's my
world so I mean obviously I'm very
nervous to do this so you might have to
ask me more questions to get me going
are you getting any sleep yeah I'm
getting plenty of sleep I mean I think
people make being a father parent out to
be way harder than it actually is
I like it so far it's been it's been
easy I mean like it's just a baby
there's uh like all you really do is you
caught a little cedar chain your diaper
and you know that's it you just make
sure she doesn't die yeah well I mean
sounds like you're keeping her alive so
we got that going for us
because know what were some of your
fears like and what have some of your
fears gone away since the babies come
into the world like what's some of that
experience been like oh absolutely
um before I was just really worried
about I don't know just providing for
and and just being a good dad because
like I said in the original calling my
dad wasn't there like I was afraid maybe
when I met her that I would be just like
him and just like just get out of the
get out of her life but I always had
this feeling that like I could be a good
dad but I just wasn't sure so I mean
after having her it's just been super
easy it feels super natural and I don't
know I mean my fears have kind of gone
away entirely honestly like I everything
is so much better
well that's like many things in life we
build up the fears in our own head and
once we actually get put in the position
you realize hey there's not that much to
be afraid of and you can proceed on and
Ravin a great job man that's awesome -
he
yeah it's pretty powerful man and think
that you know that your life was or your
childhood some of it has been one way
and then to think that you are gonna
have a new experience with your own kid
that's it's real powerful to hear that I
feel like yeah yeah thank you man I
think you should add one Thea I think
you have a kid because Jesus man I
probably think about taking care of a
plant that's taking care of a kid by an
orchid orchid with a strong heartbeat
yeah same thing
yeah nick has a question for you well
Nick so you were worried about the
implications for your girlfriend you
said she had a bright future in front of
her either she was in law school or
metal medical school um do you guys have
you kind of made a plan where she can
continue on and down that path do you
have that figured out yeah so originally
she was going to UMass Amherst oh yeah
yeah a lot of chicks put out over here
I'll tell you that's the truth bro oh
sorry sorry not her I'm not her not her
obviously you know but is the one with
them yeah sorry so you're kind of
nevermind why don't you guys finish this
question an answer sorry yeah how are
you feeling about yeah the concerns you
had for your for your baby mama well
obviously that was my my second main
concern behind the baby like I just kind
of felt like I ruined their life but you
got someone pregnant and that they have
all these big things coming ahead but
yeah we made plans like she she starting
nursing obviously it's not med school
but she did have to drop out of UMass to
go to a local community college which is
it still bothers me but you know we're
really happy so I think everything just
kind of fell into place and we're making
plans like she's doing nursing I'm
finishing up my degree it's just yeah I
mean it's cool
I feel bad about it but it worked out
yeah it sounds like it's working
positively nursing is a great job man
having a and plus she gets a couple
credit hours high for nursing that baby
you know what I'm saying
blowing milk into that little we should
send him some of this yeah we definitely
shared Oh
Jocko has a new drink out that you can
nurse as well so we'll send you some of
it it's actually really really good
brothers pineapple coconut I might [ __ ]
every lab there's some caffeine in it
yeah it's like a little little mind a
little mine I've got back working out
you can step it up oh yeah we singing a
little bit of this mind blast but dude
that's awesome and it sounds exciting it
sounds like you're definitely more in a
position of what would you say well
what's cool to me is look you have the
vision of what the path of your life is
gonna be like right everyone's got this
vision of what it's gonna be like and
the chances of you actually being able
to stay on that path are next to none
and if every time you get pushed off the
path a little bit you just surrender
well that's where that's where you end
up you know in horrible place but what
you did and you're setting a great
example for other people you and your
girl have said look we had we had this
path laid out oh we're gonna we just got
pushed off the path big time
yeah but guess what we're not
surrendering we're just readjusting the
path we're taking a little detour we're
gonna get back on eventually but the
journey is still awesome so that's what
that's what life is about man nothing
comes easy and you're gonna look back
and you're gonna be able to tell your
little girl hey this is what we did to
bring you up and and we use the
sacrifice we made it it was worth every
second so what you're doing is awesome
what your girls doing is awesome and the
the end result will be infinitely better
and more rewarding than it would have
been had you just had everything served
up to you on a silver platter like you
would like you had originally thought
okay yeah you know what's funny will you
have obviously you haven't been
listening to this whole episode because
it's not even out yet but Jocko and I've
been sitting for about 40 minutes
talking about stuff and a lot of it's
been just now how some of our back
and even I struggle with this a lot but
how some of our behaviors once we start
to set some new good behaviors for
ourselves how it will influence the next
behavior we do so yeah I mean like
pattern yeah yeah like just yeah so the
next thing that comes along for you do
it I can't after this is probably gonna
be a damn cakewalk bro you're gonna have
[ __ ] you know funny bones on your
feet you can have sugar on your shoes
brother it's gonna be a cakewalk
so it's not I heard this quote the other
day I think it was Bill Belichick he was
talking about something like let's not
just have a good day let's have a good
week let's have a good month and like
just building those patterns and those
steps so that really spoke to me and
like everything Jocko is saying and and
what you're saying like when Jocko was
just speaking I got the chills because
like exam and like that's inspirational
very I like a lot about yeah I took a
lot of what he said the first time and
and just now like it's it's pretty
unbelievable when you reach out and you
hear these things
well because yeah I mean I have some of
the same fears of my own life of having
children that sort of thing so it's all
kind of full circle dude we're all out
here just trying our best and stuff like
that but but thanks so much for calling
in man and yeah you'll definitely get
any sleep after we send you a case of
this Jacko's energy yeah that's true man
it's going pretty good I've had half of
a cigarette in two weeks so are you
lying to me
nope I'm not not feel good man I feel
pretty good man dude you know you should
have had you should have had a cigar
with Bill burr cuz yeah that dude trust
me wrong
he already burnt me at a couple of my
ends so I don't need nothing else
getting lit up in this room dude after
he spoke to me but he was in here
what up what do you have for me jack oh
thanks so much you will for uh for for
answered otter sounds beautiful
oh dude she is actually sent your
producer her little Instagram my
girlfriend man Instagram for so if you
want to look at pictures of babies then
you got a balding mole just like I'm in
I'm in brother dude she's got them all
post a nice picture of her mullet dude
she might even meet your kid I don't
know anything's possible
yeah hey I wrote a bunch of kids books
I'll send you out some kids books for
them for the little baby yeah and
actually one of the one of them says
right on the front where there's a will
mm-hmm mm-hmm pretty cool will man be
good dude we'll check in oh yeah there
she is right there baby Allah she is
pretty and she does have a mommy honor
yeah a lot of them that's very
unattractive but this baby pretty hot
I mean attractive doing do you wouldn't
you and producer Nick dude producer Nick
last night use love and pictures of
Harry I think he liked every single one
gonna be and obviously he died soon
right I told will I wasn't following
back he DM me from this baby's account I
was like will man be good dude will sing
you some of this stuff man and uh and
we'll check in we'll check in on you and
I and baby Ileana sounds good man thanks
for all you're doing
thanks Jocko no problem brother all
right stay strong cheers brother
yep man that's pretty cool huh that is
awesome that is awesome that's crazy cuz
he called me was like he didn't he was
like worried and then you hear the baby
in the background you're like that's a
live grenade bro you're scared huh yeah
I get pretty scared there's a lot of
responsibilities that word you're scared
of you think let me think about it for a
second so I can't really feel what I'm
scared about I think I'm scared not
Brett met the right girl I just don't
know I just don't know if I want my life
to change that much sometimes if I'm
ready
Oh
2:39 cool you know part of that but then
part of it like yeah I just think about
what am I scared of man because I I just
want to get it right because I think
about it sometimes like yeah I mean the
look on your face when you heard that
your eyes got big like just wait
flashback yeah like somebody just made
their own little Jurassic Park I just
don't know how I'm ready yeah judging by
the look on your face my answer is
negative give it a little bit more time
yeah I think but I think um I think I
want to be a good parent
I think if sometimes I could you and I
don't know if this is a negative way to
think about it I could use a child cause
sometimes I think it would give because
I like to care about other people it
would give me something to care about
plus plus your dad was like 87 when he
had you yeah yeah so yeah okay I got all
kinds of time what are you talking about
Jocko over here on the on the slow roll
will make this happen when it happens
no factor my mom my dad was 38 years
older so if I see like a nine-month old
you know even baby Ileana I'm not
hitting on her but I do want to know
what her work ethic is like you know I
want to know what kind of woman you see
some potential oh yeah I'm the line yeah
I'm thinking down the line Rosie
so that's pretty crazy uh we have we
have some more a couple of more good
questions that came in let's do it
hey how's it going this is Jace from
Herman Utah hey quick question for Jocko
by the way it's my dog Jocko named Matt
for you it's a cool name the answer word
because it's not anything else so there
you have it anyway
Jocko from listening to your podcast and
just some of the podcasts you've been on
it seems to me as if you may be a little
bit emotionally detached as well as
very self-critical I find these two
traits in myself to be very prevalent my
question is do you find that to be a
benefit or detriment in your life
but on the personal side I find it
difficult sometimes to relate to my
spouse my kids my friends my family
because I just simply do not understand
where they're coming from on an
emotional level so my question is do you
feel this way or have you figured out
the balance between the two anybody be
great appreciate it thank you guys for
everything you do
Thanks good question huh
this is a good question yeah yeah um you
know I definitely know this sounds like
I'm a crazy person or whatever but yeah
I try and keep control over my emotions
as we've been talking about this whole
time right like I'm not gonna fly off
the handle you know I I don't yell at
people I don't know don't are getting
big arguments with my wife in fact I
don't really even argue with my wife you
know right like hey if she's getting
emotional about something cool I just I
just like accept the emotions trying to
absorb a little bit and then figure out
how I can deescalate the situation you
know what I mean like that's that seems
to be the smart thing to do I don't
think I'm too emotionally detached I
mean I I if if you listen to my podcast
all the time you can hear sometimes I
get very emotional when I'm on there
because I'm I'm having memories of my
friends or things like that and and yeah
I'll get I'll get very emotional at
times I won't let it get out of control
you know but so I don't think I'm too
emotionally detached and and then the
other thing is being self-critical I you
know I'm definitely critical of myself
but I think I've found a good balance
there so so what does that look like I
mean how do we how do we measure that if
you're just constantly beating yourself
down yeah that is not positive so what
am I going to be self-critical I will
look at myself being so critical myself
that it's causing a negative reaction be
you're being too self-critical so
balance it out a little bit you know
you're you've got to live your life so I
always look at all these things
and same thing when you talk about not
relating to your family or whatever and
I just told the guy this on on Twitter
you know guys I K I'm having a hard time
relating with my family I'm trying to
get after it I'm trying to you know be
my best and they're not you know they
they don't get it and I'm like hey man
it's not about you
the world doesn't revolve around you
yeah you you got a family cool you need
to you need to adapt your life around
your family here's something interesting
that I said the other day like I've
written a bunch of books I wrote
probably 95% of the pages in all my
books when every single person in my
family was asleep you see what I'm
saying yeah I didn't I didn't sit there
and hey everyone leave me alone cuz I'm
trying to do this I work out in the
morning guess what no one's awake in my
family when I'm working out in the
morning like in the world so so I
sacrifice things so that I can be there
and and do what I got to do for my
family so I see so that's your journey
that's a your journey and now and what
you're doing you they don't need to
conflict right right I don't demand that
everyone is on board the same bus that
I'm on board
yeah hey oh I'll take I get on the bus
before I get on my bus and then I Drive
where I'm going and then when my little
you know when my aunt my oldest daughter
wasn't ballerina Jesus you know what
that is
okay yeah I've heard of that yeah yeah
yeah that's not my thing
right that's not I'm not into that but I
went to some damn recital and I wasn't
how close I could see you like 200 yards
away oh but knock I can't make it to
recital I got a workout tonight I wasn't
doing that I was like oh cool we're
going on the recital let's watch the
kids and of course a little bit critical
sometimes could I be like what did they
learn yeah how did that help but peers
was bloody my my daughter that was a
ballerina got more injuries
you know psycho ballet is saying it's
she got my injuries from ballet then my
other daughter did from wrestling
and gymnastics so it's a it's a tough
sports a highly and that's what I that's
what I realized I said hey you know what
she likes it it's highly disciplined
they're super strict she used to come
home I used to have to you ever seen
those things those like massage things
that you roll out it's like little
little little rollers on a stick
yeah yeah and she would come she's like
12 years old 12 years old she'd be like
can you roll out my god she'd be sitting
there with tears coming I'd be rolling
those things out because that's trying
to prevent and is you nine feet tall no
she probably got three yeah so so that's
the thing all right I'm not making the
world this is the thing the world is not
about you right so you're not
sacrificing the other things that you
have to do in your other
responsibilities hey occasionally I know
what I mean occasionally it's like hey
you know maybe I don't need to watch 14
recitals in a row right because you know
the kids will do the play or whatever
and they show it night whatever six
nights not going to six nights look I'll
be there at the Nutcracker Suite Rollo
and father drosselmeier's and the bills
exactly but I think part do you think
though that your your mentality cuz you
have to have some elements of you know
you have to have I think probably more
like grrrrrr then you know do you think
that it's tough sometimes to has is it
tough to manage I think maybe and I'm
not saying that's not what he's asking
you but I'm just saying like here's the
thing what could he be struggling with
you know he said it at the end he said
the word balance right right I wrote
that book right there called the
dichotomy leadership there you you have
to balance all these different things in
your life so so as a leader right as a
leader as a leader you gotta you got to
communicate with your people obviously
right can you communicate too much with
your people do you think you can yes oh
yes you absolutely begin where they
stopped listening to you if they can you
communicate not enough yes you can now
they don't know what's going on you got
to be somewhere in the middle
you know everyone looks me goes wrong
you're super hyper aggressive right yeah
you have to be aggressive as a leader
yeah you do cuz you gotta make things
happen can you be too aggressive oh yes
you can
yeah can you be not aggressive enough oh
yes you can so where do you have to be
you have to be in the middle you have to
be in the middle and so it's the same
thing with your with your personal life
I talk about this all the time if if I'm
okay I want to I want to build my
business whatever it is I want to do my
job and the reason I'm doing that is I
still so I can make more money if I make
more money I can can provide for my
family
so I'm doing this for my family so I'm
gonna work 89 hours a day then you look
up in six months you look up in a year
you don't have a family anymore
right they don't know who you are so you
went too far the other side of the
spectrum is you're like well I can't do
any overtime today because I gotta I
gotta go to the recital and the the
practice recital log won't be here
tomorrow either and now you look up in
six months or a year and you don't have
a job and you can't provide so what do
you have to do you have to find the
balance you have to find the balance
with how critical you are of yourself
you have to find the balance of how
detached you're gonna be if you get to
you talked about being emotionally
detached can you be too emotionally
detached absolutely you can you looking
at your kids like with a stone cold face
all the time they can't connect with you
not just your kids if you work for me if
we were in a seal platoon together which
I know is an unlikely scenario but if we
want to seal platoon together and all I
did was was no connection just said hey
here's what here's what the next mission
just go do it after a while you're like
this guy doesn't care about me right so
you're not gonna want it you're not
gonna put forth the extra effort so one
of the most important things that you
have to do with the people you work with
up and down the chain of command is form
a relationship with them same thing with
your family if you're not forming a good
relationship and maintaining a good
relationship with your family you're
gonna look up you're not gonna have a
family anymore and that's not good so
with everything that we're talking about
in life you have to maintain balance you
have to when you get out of balance and
you'll feel it you'll feel it when you
feel it when you feel like oh my wife
doesn't want me to go to jujitsu again
tonight you don't have to think my wife
doesn't ever want me to do jujitsu again
you could say oh I have to ease back a
little bit
I got a maybe if I'm gonna go I got to
spend a little bit of extra time in the
morning or
again you gotta find the balance you
don't have to go extreme one way or the
other and that's what a lot of people do
they go extreme in one direction and
then anyone that's in their way they mow
them down and that is not the long-term
results of that is never good yeah yeah
and I think leadership as well as
leading you're leading it's not just you
you know with leadership hundred percent
it's a group yeah you're there's more
than just you involved we in the long
run if you're like this is what's cool
so this is kind of weird a guy asked me
a little while ago he says he's a guy
that we have a big event a leadership
event we do it like two or three times a
year and people come and this one guy he
helps us out with it so I see him every
time we do one these a really good guy
he's got his own business real really
good guy and he follows what I do when
he sees that I'm right in 14 books and
97 podcast and all the stuff I'm doing
and he goes you know I've been watching
how much you do how much you produce
just the raw production materials he
says I don't understand how you have
enough time for your family like I don't
get it how do you do it or are you doing
it well enough and I was like you know
that's a good question and I didn't have
usually I'm like prompt with answers cuz
I can ask questions all day long like
yeah and I said you know what let me
think about it and I thought about it
and what I realized was and I came back
to him the next day and I said I have an
answer to your question he says well
what is it and I said I my family at
this point in time doesn't really need
me that much my wife is like really
independent and emotionally independent
and she doesn't need you know she sees
me and we're just totally good to go we
have fun and she knows oh you're gonna
go do something hey I get it right you
know my oldest daughter she's completely
you know she's 20 years old she's in
college she's doing her own thing she's
making things happen
actually her kid yeah you know she's at
that age I know what you're trying to
say yeah I'm making imagine yeah it was
really bad
my 18 year old daughter my 18 year old
daughter same thing like she's on her
own program she you know she'll text me
and like but she's my I have a 16 year
old son
he's on his own program he's fully self
functional like self supportive they
don't need me and then the only one
that's a little bit needy is is my
ten-year-old because she's standing no
she's still a ten-year-old so so that's
where I can focus my efforts because
she's younger so my point in saying all
that is is that through the years I
balanced you know I would just
constantly balance and and you know
raise the kids where they are
self-sufficient where they don't rely on
me to do everything for him my wife the
same way my wife's not relying on you
know my wife will handle stuff right
whatever it is she can handle it yeah
you got to get a capable woman people
that's one thing if you pick an
incapable wife dude that's gonna be here
yeah and the most part of that capable
is emotionally capable because when you
end up with a spouse whether it's the
man or the woman that relies on you to
make them feel good emotionally that's
the one that will pick you apart so you
gotta be careful that one's a good one
to look out for so in the end of the day
I guess what I'm saying is you got to
have balance you got to build a strong
structure and the point I was gonna say
with this guy is is Jace you what while
you're investing in your family you're
building them you're making your family
stronger so that they can stand on their
own set in the long run you have more
freedom in your life because you you
won't have this family unit that's
totally reliant on you for every little
thing yeah which is by the way makes
them better off in the world when they
grow up they go out and they dominate a
world because they're capable yeah
damn dude yeah I don't think anybody
taught me [ __ ] growing up I don't know
if I know about didn't you learn a lot
of stuff from Daniel who's drinking hot
hose water bro first sip oh no I know I
know I heard you talking on the podcast
about how like your first girl is sort
of like the hot hose water and I was
thinking all that doesn't really make
any sense and then I realized it does
because here's what happens with the hot
hose water when you first take when you
first start drinking it yeah it's all
hot and uncomfortable but then all of a
sudden you get to the coal party like oh
yeah
so it's the same thing with your first
girl you're kind of like awkward it's
all bike doesn't taste good and all of a
sudden you get kind of through that to
the coldness yeah okay this is good
so yeah you do remember that first hose
pipe yeah dude one of my first
girlfriends that real short hair dude
and she look like a young man you know
and I don't know if I really wanted to
be her boyfriend but I don't know if I
had a choice yeah you're just oh dude
bro
she stood when the school bus would come
he would bring my brother and his
friends from the bigger school after
[Laughter]
let's make one more go over jock on it
all right
one quick patreon and then we'll end on
a video questions what war this is from
Jacob wells what war movie or TV show is
the most realistic based on his combat
experiences oh that's great and Jacob
wells actually know him and he's from he
has like nine brothers and sisters and
um and I've met him at a group of show
you from Oklahoma
he should have a podcast he has great
questions like almost every week I want
to pick his question a really neat guy
yeah what so what's the there's an HBO
miniseries there's two of them one on
what's called Band of Brothers which you
may or may not have seen it's about the
European theater it's about the first of
Ivo 6 or the second of five or six
battalion and fighting an easy company
it's it's fantastic from a leadership
perspective from a tactical perspective
that one's awesome and then they made a
few years later they made one for the
Pacific Theatre which is called the
Pacific and it's based on several books
which are outstanding books I've covered
all the books that that series is based
on on my podcast
it's it's called the Pacific it's about
the Pacific island campaign and the
first time I watched it I was I was I
remember I was on a plane and I had like
the noise cancelling headsets on and I
was staring at like my iPad was a c-130
no no no I was in civilian clothes
already civilian so staring at this
thing you know four inches from my face
so I was super absorbed in it and what
what they did in that but what makes me
always remember how impactful that that
series was to me was they land on this
island and you're expecting this big
crazy battle to break out but it doesn't
and so it's showing them patrolling
through the jungle they're patrolling
basically looking for the Japanese and
the Japanese you know had decided oh gee
Meyer no no yeah they decided that they
were going to let the Americans land and
then hit them
so these scenes where they're just
patrolling through the jungle and you
know that they're waiting you're waiting
for the enemy to attack and we're not my
last deployment to Iraq I was in this
place called Ramadi and when you would
walk down the streets or I'd be watching
my guys walk down the streets or
watching some soldier or watching some
Marines and the whole time you're
watching you're waiting you're just
waiting for the enemy to attack and
you're waiting for bullets to come down
the stream and so I had watching that I
had that same kind of anxiety and that's
when I realized how powerful that that
miniseries is so those two are great and
those are those are probably my favorite
war I don't call movies but they're
scenes or it's a miniseries that's what
it is right yeah I can yeah I cannot I
cannot really imagine that if it can
take somebody like you kind of to that
place with that tension it's so
interesting it's like yeah combat is one
thing but that the energy before
something happens sometimes you're so
severe knowing someone's intent knowing
someone else kind of knows that intent
but they don't really know where the the
intersection is going to occur just that
kind of milling around yeah and like we
just
talk to will the anticipation of
something is always worse yeah and so
when you know that it was coming and
when when you were on patrol in Ramadi
uh yeah you knew it was coming you knew
it was coming and so it's just that
anticipation and from a leadership
perspective your biggest fear from my
biggest fear was always you know one of
my guys yeah
and that's that's it's the it's a
sickening feeling in your gut and
there's nothing you can do about it I
mean you do everything you can to
mitigate risk but you just you just and
I had that same feeling watching the the
scenes from a Pacific winner patrolling
through the jungle if a guy gets hit
dude they look at cue yeah it depends on
the situation right it depends on the
situation that whoever that leader is in
that moment is gonna step up make calls
make things happen it might be the
youngest guy depends who's there was
there ever a moment where you had to
order guys into a certain situation and
and something happen and you're like and
it fell on you kind of where the guy
looked at you even after he'd been yeah
so the weird thing about special
operations for us on that deployment was
if every mission that we did was a
mission that I had said yes we should do
this okay so that's every one of these
situations where one of my guys got
wounded or one of my guys got killed
it's a hundred percent on me
I mean hundred percent because I'm the
one that's approving the plan I'm the
one that's saying yes this is what we're
gonna do and that's that's one of the
that's one of the different types of
stress that you get in Special
Operations because in a conventional
unit generally not always but they're
they're getting a little bit more
tasking from higher hey here's what you
guys are going to do you can figure out
how you want to do it but this is what
you're gonna do no one was really
tasking me most of the time it was my
guys coming up with plans hey this is
what we think was me doing misses me
saying yeah it's a good plan so yeah
that's something that you and you're
right there whether you're not getting a
golf cart or something it depends on
this it depends on the situation I mean
I had basically 40 seals sometimes they
were in elements as small as five guys
and they'd be out there some
have three or four elements out on the
battlefield the same time I would be
back in a tactical operation center
sometimes I'd go if it was a big giant
kind of combined operation where we were
working with a lot of different units
I'd go out with them sometimes I'd go
out with them just to go out with them
but sometimes the best place most of the
time the best place for me to control
what was happening was in the Tactical
Operations Center that's just the way it
is
yeah and so yeah it's it's one of those
things that as a leader I mean you're
you're ultimately responsible for
everything that happens and that's a
that's a heavy burden to bear and it's
the one that's it's one that you're
gonna have to live with for the rest of
your life and it's it's one that I wake
up with every single day and I'll I'm
not I'm not mad about that I'm not mad
about that burden in fact to me that
burden is a reminder of the guys that
made the ultimate sacrifice and I'm
honored to have had the experience of
serving with them yeah and yeah I can't
imagine this the this the camaraderie
the the repercussions of such severe
camaraderie as going to war with people
you know that's it it's yeah it's
something that I yeah I couldn't even
imagine oh it's sudden it's something
that I could even recreate emotionally
or inside of my own brain really you
know it's it's it's pretty fascinating
because it's so severe it's just such a
there's such a finality that your
finality is right there on the line yeah
and you do you develop the strongest
Brotherhood with the people you're on
the battlefield with and we were working
with alongside soldiers and Marines all
the time and the relationships that we
develop with them you know every time
someone gets which in Ramadi there was a
guy get there was guys getting wounded
and killed every day you know you're
going to their memorial services and
your ceiling seeing the the angel
flights which they call them as which is
when they take their bodies out on the
last you know on their last helicopter
ride home and
yeah it's it is it's very severe and
it's one of those things that I mean
there's nothing for me there's nothing
else will ever compare with all that
there's just nothing nothing in life
will will impact me as much leave me
with as much pride and at the same time
as much sorrow as those days for me and
that's the way most guys end up feeling
about about being in the being in the
military and going overseas on
deployment did go into experiences like
that where people are losing their lives
and people are losing their abilities
and their capabilities in war and in you
know in combat did it has it adjusted
your faith at all over the years or has
it affected that at all or is it created
it or you know the biggest thing is from
what I've seen right when you see when
you're in war you get to see the
absolute best in human beings and you
get to see the absolute worst in human
beings I mean we saw unspeakable evil
right so if you want to talk about Satan
you want to talk about pure evil you
when you go to war you get to see it you
when you face an enemy like like the
insurgents in the battle or Ramadi that
were doing the most heinous things that
you can imagine then you realize that
evil absolutely exists and whatever you
want to attach that to you can do it
because it's there and at the same time
you also get to see you get to see
humanity that's making sacrifices above
and beyond
anything that a normal human being would
do pure good and so from a faith
perspective what you get to see with
your own eyes
is evil pure evil and you get to see
pure good and that I think that it
leaves an impact on everybody and
definitely left them left a mark on me
for sure
what you got net the last video sure
let's do
super-quick one that'll be a really
quick answer just because I'm curious as
well and then end on a one that he can
expand on actually oh come
hey what's up few of these questions for
a Jocko
I was wondering what your best
powerlifting numbers were ever and what
your powerlifting numbers are currently
dan dan you know this guy's trying to be
your chef or something this guy's gonna
spot you my traditional answer when
people ask me what what kind of weights
I'm lifting is not enough no because
you're always trying to get better and
trying to get stronger yeah of course
you are
yeah well at least I am so let's see I
think that the most I've ever deadlift
it
you know that this is another big you
know you're asking me what people think
you but when they meet me Oh people try
ask is this all the time no they ask all
this all time they also think that I'm
some superhuman athlete which I'm not
I'm not I'm not and I've explained this
over and over again
I wasn't defense I'm not the fastest I'm
not the strongest I wasn't like I'm not
this super athlete and I explain that to
people all the time even jiu-jitsu
people like oh that guy could never get
tapped out come to my gym watch me get
tapped out like it's the it's the
reality of it well but yeah to try and
answer this guy's question without
avoiding the question or whatever I mean
I hardly be honest jakka yeah to Kansas
I hardly I hardly ever I hardly ever
bench press anymore because because I
don't like it you're an adult
yeah well I don't like what it does to
my shoulders yeah I know deadlift the
most I've ever deadlift is five five
hundred Jesus which is no that's not
that's that's on five yeah that's that's
I don't know what I'd be dead lifting
today even though you know I deadlift on
the regular yeah but I'll do it I'll do
it I'll do yeah you know what it's like
yeah yeah squat is another one I mean
you know you know this is one of those
ones where from a powerlifting
perspective I don't know what the actual
number would be cuz like when I squat I
I go all the
way down like into the hole can you
really do it yeah well no I'm not not
saying that it's just that that's what I
do
right um I don't even know what my
numbers would be right would you have
green plates on each side you think yeah
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
3:15 but yeah dude to answer your
question I'm not I'm not some super
strong dude you probably know if you're
working if you're a power lifter you're
stronger than me I'm not like well not
you yeah saying you could take me in a
minute but if I'm gonna [ __ ] slicks
ooh yeah what the most I benched ever
was it's not some huge allure it's funny
when I was at SEAL team - there was a
guy in my platoon who was this old short
guy he looked kind of chubby and I
actually went through SEAL training with
him and he was he could run faster than
me and he could bench more than me yeah
this little and he was a great guy he's
a great seal but you know if you looked
at the two of us you'd be like oh yeah
Jaco could carska no he could run faster
than me and bench more on me you know do
you think at some point it comes down to
this like people's mud there's something
different in certain people's muscles
the way their bodies are built for sure
there's their you heard a fast twitch
muscle twitch muscle there's another
kind of muscle called medium twitch
muscle oh yeah and that's what I have my
muscle I know likes to watch Cold Case
Files I'm definitely notice I have I
have a lot of what's called medium
twitch muscle so if I put a rucksack on
I can go for a long time and not get
tired I can almost on right and I would
lose in a sprint but if you put me with
a rucksack on I can go I can go for a
long time it's good for a grappling like
not wrestling because wrestling's super
explosive yeah but fir Jiu Jitsu for a
long like you want to roll for 40
minutes I'm good and I'll stage steady
that whole time what professional
wrestler did you ever seen you're like
oh yeah I'm like that guy I don't you
know I've never really got that into
wrestling yeah into professional
wrestling if you threw some names out I
might be able to remember one or two I
meant Hulk Hogan won t did he was large
he yeah he's big he like I guess they
all you you lose
perspective when you see him oh yeah
yeah TV but he's he was a really big guy
yeah dang I think um yeah I think his
daughter had a crush on me for a little
bit but I could be making it up but um
here this guy is a question cool
Jacko Co first things first this stuff
is good question is if a guy is upper
20s early 30s is it even worth
considering enlisting and contributing
to eventually the NCO corps or would you
recommend every time to go the officer
out and to make this a little bit more
broad of a question for the general
audience would how would you apply this
question to a generic entry-level
position at a large organization that's
been established for a long time or
trying to just go in straight to a
management position do you understand
that question Thiel I do but I want to
make sure that you do
I guess he means no I don't okay so in
the military there's basically two it's
like a caste system okay there's
officers yeah and there's enlisted
people officers are like the prescribed
leaders okay
and there's enlisted people which are
those prescribed grunts okay how within
the grunts there's a rank structure and
you can advance up to that rank
structure on the enlisted side on the
officer side there same thing you
advance as you go forward
ei e4 III yeah that's that the enlisted
side okay so you start off as an e1 yeah
and then you go up through eat any nine
I'd be any walk I think yeah the officer
same thing now the only difference
between these two people is the officers
went to college so if you go to college
you but you can go in as an officer it's
not guaranteed but you can go as an
officer what I did I started off and
listed and I got picked up for this
awesome program and got moved over to
the officer side so I got to do both so
his question is he's a little bit older
should he try and become an officer and
or if that doesn't work or should he go
and list it maybe not if it doesn't work
because I
and say here's what you should do you're
older you got some experience in life if
you can try and become an officer that's
fine if you can't because it's it's more
selective to become an officer
immediately go go into the enlisted
situation the other question that people
ask me a lot when they're twenty nine
thirty years old they kind of life they
got a family they got a job but they all
of a sudden they wake up one day and say
man I don't feel like I've sacrificed I
don't feel like I've given enough to the
country I want to do something yeah I
remember ask you that last time we were
on yeah and I probably gave the same
answer which is go on the check out the
reserves should go and see go in the
National Guard go in the Army Reserves
go on the Marine Corps go in the
reserves so where you do one weekend a
month and two weeks in the summertime
now do you have to remember that you
could get called up when we got to the
Battle of Ramadi that whole area was
controlled by reservists from you know
guys that were in the National Guard
there's a National Guard unit out of
Pennsylvania they were total studs but
you can they were there for 14 months I
think fighting so you know these guys
were teachers and plumbers and
electricians and whatever and all of a
sudden they were their fighters yeah so
it can really happen you can't just
think Oh it'll never happen no it can
absolutely happen but I think that's a
good thing to do and as far as which one
you should go into I mean I loved the
fact that I went in as a grunt Brian
came up and and and romantic about that
kind of yeah there's some well there's
just a weird way I guess if you're weird
but but there's also some some factual
things right you learn all what it's
like you learn from the front lines what
it's like to be a grunt so now when you
get moved over to the officer you you
gain at least you have experience and
you might you understand it but that
being said there's great people that's
called a prior enlisted officer there's
some prior enlisted officers that are
awesome because they have that
experience there's also some prior
enlisted officers that are just as bad
as any other officer and there's
officers that never were enlisted that
are fantastic it really boils down to
you and your personality and your
leadership capabilities that's what's
gonna make you good or not not the
experience you have just like you know
there's some colleges like the Naval
Academy or the Air Force Academy or West
Point
No Citadel you go to four years learning
how to be a military man or military
woman and you might think I don't know I
thought this I thought man those guys
are gonna be so good cuz they have all
this all this knowledge it's not true
there are some great ones there's also
some bad ones you could there was some
great guys that went to 13 weeks of
Officer Candidate School and then
Warrant Officer and they were awesome
some of them were not awesome so it
really what really matters is what you
bring to the table that's what matters
the move all right
I remember the ROTC kids they used to
just end up they all bought race cars
used to race them out back of the school
and everything and then and they have
them then do [ __ ] I don't think but do
you think if we that was a dead and if
there ever was but that whole story like
kind of sunk my heart a little bit I
second it to go somewhere I'm gonna just
with the silence we good yeah that's one
of those things you scratch off the list
of things to talk about out of the gate
man if we if we fought aliens or when we
fight aliens yes or robots do you think
we will have a chance yes would you rate
robots arrive through robots out because
people are always asking me about the
robot wars
I think robots yeah I'm just hope
there's no like you know I think robots
will be fine I'm gonna beat up a [ __ ]
microwave I know what I'm saying dude
I'll beat the [ __ ] out of a toaster with
that but what I'm saying is especially
if I had like in a can and a half ago
right now dude don't say no [ __ ]
sucks out a high undying right now well
what I'm saying is this aliens in the
aliens come would you reenlist yes okay
yeah and who would you take in a battle
with you it's just like it's like that
movie Armageddon you gotta take five
people into battle with you oh I got a
list of guys yeah okay well rattle off a
couple sir
well I can't cuz they're you know oh
okay yeah they're working Oh
we can't use her names that they're
working yeah okay well most of them
right okay
okay well let's say then I had a guy I
have had a guy on my podcast couple
times his name is Tony or fratty and he
him and I grew up in the SEAL Teams
together and then he was one of the
platoon chiefs over in Ramadi with me
and I actually started off the podcast
saying hey if there's some if there's a
list there's everyone has a list of guys
that hey if it goes down I'm bringing
him tony is one of the guys Tony's an he
would be out on like a five day
operation in a hundred and twenty degree
heat and he'd bring nothing with him but
a can of Copenhagen in like a little
half liter bottle of water oh I felt
like doing cocaine there's no factory no
factory and no no calls about it at all
homes at all
Wow make them coconut Copenhagen's soup
yeah so yeah there's a bunch of guys
like that man there's a bunch of just
guys that are just that's what they're
born to do man that's what they're born
to do from the Jocko podcast man thank
you so much brah we're coming in dude so
is so awesome man cuz it's sometimes
life is like you never know kind of what
you need and then life kind of like
gives you you know it just kind of the
where you where you're where you are is
where you're supposed to be you know
it's like someone realize that I
appreciate being here today man thank
you so much dude thanks man appreciate
it yeah
[Music]
little town for me to sell that parking
brake and let myself
[Music]